okay so let's start the last session for
today with applications of recovery
bility okay thanks for the introduction
okay so this talk is about six different
papers all of which have in common the
common theme of applying ideas for Mac
of ability from confirmation theory to
physical scenarios where they can either
give us new insights into previous
results or give us completely new
results okay in particular i'll be
talking about these papers so working
reversibility in quantum dynamics and
tropic uncertainty and measure ability
and a measurement with reversibility
approximate reversibility in the context
of entropy gain information gained and
complete positivity from clocks the
cloners cattleya transformations under
covalent operations and recover ability
information theoretic limitations on the
proximate quantum cloning and
broadcasting and finally Diane cool maps
quantum detail balance and pics recovery
map okay so I'll start with a brief
background so done pets in 1986 made the
following discovery namely that for
every quantum Channel M the relative
entropy given by this formula here is
constant I under the application of a of
the channel the it doesn't decrease or
increase if and only if whoa and Sigma
can both be recovered perfectly so by
perfectly i mean if and only if the
existing recover recovery map until that
that can reverse the action of the
channel on row and similarly for sigma
okay pet Gator explicit form of this
recovery this recovery map given by this
formula here which is now known as the
pics recovery map you see some important
features it only depends on the state
Sigma and on the particular map m okay
where this this is the adjoint map here
okay so later in 2014 undress winter and
Kayleen
well interesting the question of whether
or not they could improve the data
processing inequality which just tells
us that under the action of a chav of a
channel the relative entropy is
non-decreasing ok 44 although in Sigma
so they were with this in mind they came
up with the following conjecture which
is they exist a recovery map n tilde
which is not necessarily Petra covering
my butt some pepper we cover them up
such that the the left hand side of the
buffer quality can be improved by
replacing 0 with this this quantity is
greater than 0 which quantifies how well
one can we cover from the loss of work
well from the action of the the channel
on the state Sigma okay so it turns out
that they I mean they kind of knew at
the time that this result can't be true
for the pitch recovery map but they were
hoping that perhaps it was true for
another recovery map although now since
then it's kind of most people think it's
probably not true for there's probably
not a nice recovery map that has some of
the nice features of the pitch week of
Amir Peretz recovery map for which this
is true however what is is true is that
one can prove this this inequality to be
true for particular for particular
channels n ok so if there's some
physical constraint on the channel then
under circumstances we can prove it's
true and when we can prove it's true we
can actually improve a lot of prove upon
lots of previous results ok and that
will be one of the main part well themes
doing this talk we're will show in
circumstances for which is true and for
which we can improve ok also and it's
likely another Themis people have also
been asked asking the questions that ok
well if if we can't prove this
conjecture can we prove a slightly
weaker version which is true which is
you know provably true football for all
maps
and there's been a few papers on this by
various authors I i if you're interested
i recommend you see the top by debbie
SATA form last q IP but the basic I
result was that we can there does exist
the universal place recovery map for
which this is true but now the rather
than the relative entropy we have to
replace if minus to log the fidelity ok
which is a slightly weaker weaker
constraint and also if and this recovery
map universal no sense they only depends
on on Sigma and a generalized pet
recovery map ok i also just quickly
mention that i recommend you stay for
the next talk to see how people actually
improve this even further where they can
replace this by a so-called measured
relative entropy ok but that that's
that's the next talk by David Sutta ok
so let's look at applications so okay
the first thing I'll talk about is the
work convertibility in quantum dynamics
ok so as you has heard from the
tutorials by Lydia and the talks by
Jonathan and and and some other people
in in confirm dynamics were what we're
interested in normally is characterizing
state transitions between a state road
to state Sigma under some thermodynamic
context and with the rules of quantum
mechanics ok so there are various
different particular thermodynamic maps
which people have come up with which
vary slightly in exact context but here
for example we'll talk first about this
particular cloak clasp which is known as
correlating catalytic thermo operations
which are defined in the following ways
so we consist of three or more catalyst
the state row we want to make the state
transition on and the third and and all
this is in the context of a thermal
baths at some background state
temperature okay in a Gibb state and to
all of this were allowed to apply energy
preserving unit Ares and then we trace
out over the the bath and the catalyst
okay with with the constraints that the
catalyst has to be locally returned okay
so they may have correlations but
locally to have to be the same after the
application of this unitary and there
can be no final catalyst system
correlations okay so under this context
what what the author show is that the we
can show that this Lee winter conjecture
is true for this particular map and it
has a very nice interpretation in terms
of work extraction okay which is the
following imagine under the cct
operations we want to go from 0 to Sigma
but now we want to extract some work in
the process so by this I mean we we
initially start with a battery in the
ground state and we go to the battery in
the excited state where with some
eigenvalue w which we can associate with
the work we can extract in this process
okay and then once we've done that we
can now with another see cct operation
we can try and reverse the process so
now go from row sorry from signal back
to roll again but without extracting any
work so the state of the battery now
will stay the same Akane excited state
and it is think we're trying to recover
road from Sigma without work extraction
okay so in this context what we what we
proved is that the amount of work you
can extracting the first step okay is
lower bounded by the relative entropy
between Sigma and the recovered versing
of Rho which where this recover vs. is
precisely the pet recovery map cause
bonding to to the cattle in thermo
operations okay and what's more is that
this is not only true only for catalytic
thermo operations but we truly show that
we can get very similar results for
Gibbs preserving mouths thermal
operations catalytic some operations and
system both correlating catalytic
celebrations which is a class of
operations which my physical sense we
define in the paper what's also very
interesting here is that within every
particular class of operation the
recovery map also belong to that
particular class okay so everything in
that sense is self pumping ok so now to
talk about the next application which is
entropy uncertainty and measurement
reversibility okay so entropic
uncertainty relations with quantum site
information relate in tandem and
uncertainty and measurement disturbance
okay so we can understand this in the
following set up imagine
have a tripod system of Alice Bob and
Eve and Alice performs one of two
measurements we've posted by the
measures okay over an ex measurement or
Zed measurement so the state then we'll
then collapse into two these two forms
where this is an orthogonal basis which
encodes the classical information about
the X measurement and similarly there's
an orthogonal basis which encodes
information about the said measurement
ok when everyone is performed ok ok so
in this context is it's well known that
the following inequality which tells us
that the conditional entropy or analysis
system after the X measurement is
performed given the knowledge of Bob
system plus the conditional entropy or
analysis system after Zed measurement is
performed given the knowledge of each
system is lower bounded by this term
here where C is just a maximum of the
positive value measures of either
measurements in the Infinity normal n
squared and this quantity is known to be
between zero and one ok so this was
already known but with ideas of
recoverability Mario Stephanie in mark
managed to enhance this inequality by
adding an additional term the right hand
side ok where this term is just a
fidelity between the initial state of
Alice and Bob and and the recovered
version of over and of the the state
after Alice's performed the X
measurement on us announcer Bob and this
can be understood as how well Alice can
recover after you know by another
measurement her initial state if she has
access to Alison Bob's system so this is
normally interpreted as a trade-off
between Bob's ability to predict to
predict the outcome of the X measurement
given access to his own system versus
the the ability of Eve to predict the
outcome of the Z measurement given
access to her system and what this does
is adds to the picture and
term which captures the ability of Alice
to recover her stage with a measurement
to unbasic to undo her measurement if
the X measurement is performed ok ok so
the the next application is an
approximate visibility in the context of
entropy gain information gained and
complete positivity so entropy is
non-decreasing under unit or maps we
will know that you to the DPI the data
person is its processing inequality but
what they do is that they have a new
bound which basically proves that the
winter conjecture is true for unit 2 and
subunit or maps which allows one to
enhance enhance this so basically what
they show is that the entropy production
due to the map which is this quantum the
left-hand side is lower bounded by the
ventra p between row and a recovered
version of row after the application of
the unit or supplemental channel ok and
this recovery map here is again it's the
pets recovery map ok so they basically
proved the early winter conjecture is
true here ok ok so both families
interpretation of this is that it's a
restricted strengthening of the second
law for adiabatic processes or in other
words that not only is the entropic
adiabatic process necessary versa pool
but also an almost isentropic adiabatic
process is almost reversible some
applications of this sign in the context
of bosonic channels where we can
quantify how well an amplified channel
can reverse the action of I attenuator
channel and vice versa so for full
details recommend you look at the paper
ok so the next paper want to talk about
is from clocks the corners and elliptic
transformations under covalent
operations and recoverability so what is
the context see the context is is that
of the resource view of asymmetry ok so
it within this resource eve of a
symmetry we have much richer cool
covariant which are simply you can
understand in the following way so
associated with the symmetry we have a
symmetry group G and we can construct
the unitary representations of the group
elements which will I don't know here ug
and then the the map epsilon is
covariant if it's a
commutes with the action of all the
group elements okay in the unitary
representations so when that's true it's
called parent likewise a state is called
symmetric when it commutes so when it's
invariant under a unitary transformation
by given by the unit a representation of
the group elements okay so in this
context what people generally interested
in is is understanding state
transformation from say from voter Sigma
however under well under these covalent
channels however if the state row has is
a symmetric and Sigma is a symmetric
then this transformation is impossible
under with covariant channels this is
analogous to saying in the resource
period of entanglement that if you have
a state that has no entanglement then
you cannot create a state with
entanglement under locc okay so in the
same way then tagme is a resource in
this theory asymmetry the resource okay
however we will still like to make these
transformations happen so how can we try
and get around this limitation well we
can add what's called a catalyst to the
picture okay and then when we do so if
this catalyst has some amount of
asymmetry then this transformation
should be approximately possible it
won't be completely possible but we want
the catalyst to return the initial state
but if it's almost returned it should be
approximately true so what are the
motivations for this well this has
applications in reference frames when
the catalyst represents a reference
frame for example it could be the
reference frame of the orientation or
the qubit or it could also be a
reference to time okay a reference for a
reference for time other applications
include in cloning where the catalyst
represent the the state's you you want
to clone and we'll talk more about this
in the in the next paper okay so okay so
what do the guys achieve here so what
they what they they do is well before
that I have to introduce first a measure
of asymmetry namely the relative entropy
of asymmetry okay which is defined as
follows so you take the state you
calculate the world to venture people in
your state and symmetric state and then
take the infimum of all symmetric stakes
okay so what they basically show is that
the fidelity to which
you can achieve this transformation is
related to what is the increase in
relative entropy drinking of you know
from the desired transformation okay or
more my explicitly speaking if we're is
symmetric then the fidelity exist
covalent a map such that the fidelity
between the the output and the input the
map is a lower bounded by this quantity
here where this is simply the change in
the relative entropy of asymmetry
between the desired you are the initial
state and the desired final state okay
so the one you would like to achieve
okay so what are selling features here
well one one one interesting thing is
that the covariant up to prevent
rotations in the input output state the
covariant map here is exactly the page
recovery map okay so this is a
application of recoverability to get
this result okay one other interesting
things we see that in order to
characterize his fidelity we only need
one particular measure of asymmetry okay
so this is this is not normal because
normally in these theories you need
various measures asymmetry and perhaps
one of the reasons here why we can only
we can get away of unusual one is the
fact that the initial state is a
symmetric but if you wanted to
generalize this to the way you have some
amount of asymmetry then perhaps would
need you know to include more motions by
symmetry okay and the next thing old to
talk about is information theoretic
limitations on approximate quantum
cloning and broadcasting okay so first
off what is the context so imagine we
have a map that takes us from a from
system 80 system a B and let's define
the output for an import row a as Sigma
alt-a be okay so then a broadcasting
channel can be understood when the the
the the reduced States on a and B are
both equal in their equal to the input
state ok and then cloning is as a
subclass of these channels where we
construct we restrict the output also be
tensor product okay so this is a highly
desirable thing in quant information
theory to be able to do and for
watchin we have some no-go theorem
shatters that we can't do this perfectly
wish or the following so the the no
broadcast in theorem tells us that if we
have to mix tape Row 1 and Row 2 then we
can only simul taneously broadcast them
if and only if they both commute by
simultaneously here I simply mean that
we use the same the same map for both
row 1 and Row 2 okay and we have
similarly even more constrained with
constraints in the case of cloning okay
and okay so this is very desirable but
of course because it can't be achieved
perfectly then the you know the
million-dollar question is how well can
we actually do it okay so for these
people came up with what is known as the
universal pond and cloning machines
which can take us always can clone k
copies to to a large number n of copies
okay so this particular machine is
optimal as autumn alone in a sense of
wealth of pure states in a sense of the
fidelity of the margins the output stage
to the input state is optimal okay so
it's as close to 21 as possible okay so
generally in this context people most
well most results concern the case where
the input state is a is K copies of a
pure q dates state and the output status
is more generally on n and n suckin n
sites where n is greater than K so in
the case that we restrict the inputs
state to be to live in the symmetric
subspace or k qubits you know its image
respect to exchange then rain hard
Verner came up with an explicit form of
this of this machine which is the
following where where this quantity here
is simply the matter you mix take in the
subs in the symmetric subspace okay and
these factors here are some common
torial factors which means the output
status is normalized which I want going
to occur there some from coming at all
factors okay so what do we what is the
result of these guys okay so um if we
define this that this is the result and
you can interpret as follows if we
define this quantity here is simply the
partial trace over n minus K cubed in
the symmetric subspace okay and how this
result from the interpretive is follow
so we can understand it
it's it's it bounds the ability of the
universal quantum coding machine from
k2n sites to it will bounce its ability
to recover estate on NQ dates after the
loss of n minus k sites okay and it's
bound by the decrease in the distinguish
ability in the relative entropy between
the state on the q date state on end
sides we expect to the maximum extent in
subspace after the action of losing or
partially tracing out n minus k sites
okay so what the second features here
well those a day they to show this
result they show that the lee winter
conjecture is true again and not only
that but the the it turns out that the
universal quantum cloning machine is the
Petra covering up for the channel for
the partial trace channel with us with
with the state being this marketing mix
late in the Subspace there's also a dual
version of this which I won't get into
it's very interesting which if you're
interested i recommend you speak to mark
or look at the paper okay so um why this
is interesting is because it implies a
well-known special case in the
literature the ring had bernard arrived
in 98 namely that if we restrict this
date on NQ dates to be a copies of a
pure state then the fidelity to which we
can clone from k copies and copies is
not bounded by discontent 20 factors ok
so this result implies this with some
bass in paul manipulations and but
interesting it here can be derived from
the more general context of
recoverability rather than the other
measures during hot burner used not in
that this particular results as well is
also attributed to Iman and steph in
which which gets results using again
recoverability but looking at the point
of view of asymmetry okay yeah so
as I see see the paper for for more
details okay so the last thing I want to
talk about is dynamical maps quantum
detail balance and pet recovery nap ok
so the context is that whenever you have
a quantum system interacting with an
environment and the interaction is
Markovian then we can describe the
dynamics of the system as an open portal
system with a one-parameter dynamical
semigroup okay which genetically have
this type of form where Sigma accounts
for the unitary part of the dynamics and
L here accounts for the dissipative part
of the coven of the dissipative parts of
the dynamics where we have information
loss and irreversibility okay so within
this context Davis in the seventies
basically proved that when we have an
environment that's the thermal okay at
some temperature T that we can do then
through unitary dynamics on the system
and under in this environment in the
weak coupling limit and the Bahnhof
limit we can derive the dynamical
semigroup for this particular setup
wishes of this form okay which has the
following property so it has a fixed
point of the match the Gibb state of the
system at the same temperature of the
environments from above so basically
it's just saying that when so this is
just basically saying that when your
infirmity libram the bath then that's a
fixed point of your map so it's kind of
to be expected also another property
this map satisfies known as quantum
detail balance with which our liquid
arrived in the 70s which I won't go into
this art form but basically it's a
constraint on the dissipative part of
the dynamics which basically constrains
you in the sense that if your state of
the system is in is the third is this
thermal state okay then the probability
of any transition with the bath is equal
to the probability of the reverse
process okay so this is basically some
kind of stability condition that when
your firm more than you stay firm order
there's no probabilistic waiting trying
to push you out or from the thermal
state okay so in this contact what
people very interested
in something called entropy production
which is commander can be understood and
fall in setting because the initiative
the of the system is not necessary more
then it will try to reach equilibrium
whipped bath and in doing so you'll get
entry with the entropy production ok so
this entropy production can be
characterized by the difference in free
energies of the initiative the system
and the state and the free energy of the
system at time T and this is roughly
approximately equal to the difference in
increasing entropy zuv the bath in the
system at time T ok so in this context
oh ok in this context what we managed to
prove is the following thing so actually
a direct consequence of any dynamical
semigroup which satisfies his quantum
data balance is the following that the
pet recovery map can be solved to have
this very nice form which if we compare
with with the map itself we see if I
don't go up to this minus sign so what
does telling us is that the remember
that Lita is the unitary part of the
dynamics so what I was telling us is
that the best way to recover is to
simply reverse the unitary part of the
dynamics and that's completely to be
expected since you two dynamics has no
information loss so the best way to
recover if you don't lose anything is
simply just do the reverse operation
however what is a bit surprising perhaps
is that for the decision that this
dissipative part of the dynamics what
the pics recovery map tells us is that
rather than at each one to reverse this
that this dissipative part what we
should do is problem going backwards in
time should try and go forwards in time
to you know to the same amount of time
that we are but again forward okay and
this is a direct consequence of quantum
data balance okay and what we also
managed to show in this context is that
the Leeuwin to conjecture holds for
these paper for these davis maps so when
you put all together we get this
following inequality on entropy
production which basically tells us that
the entry produced at time T is lower
bounded by the relative entropy between
the initial state of the system and the
state of system time to t in the future
okay so some some nice features is that
this bound is tight and what I mean by
tight is the following so okay so it's
clear why we have a factor of two when
you understand this concept
on reversibility and we're trying to
recover and the Patriot map has this
volume form but had i just presented
this bound to you maybe one your first
questions will be saved oh but why two
and not three what it turns out to
remarkably that if we replace this with
a copper then for any cup of greater
than to this band this is not true it's
not universally it's not doesn't hold
for all Davis maps okay so there's a
very special feature here that to his
tights ok and ok so it can be
generalized to further to other maps ok
so that's the end of the talk and I'd
like to have thank you for listening and
and hope you have interesting questions
[Applause]
questions
let me get started perhaps so in these
applications yes is it usually important
or how important is it that it's really
the relative entropy and not let's say
the measured relative entropy that's um
okay so it's a good question so i think
that the chair is we phone to the factor
if you meant at the beginning of the
talk i said that you should also see the
following talk to see how this the this
universally the you know this bandit
that's known to hold in general can be
tightened by you know replace when we
have the measured relative entropy and
then the question is can all these
results be improved even further if we
use the mate outside the measured
relative entropy which is known to be
true and there are a few cases where in
this talk where we did not use that we
do not make well whether the lee winter
conjecture was not proven so we used as
well so the officers are slightly more
general version and i imagine in this
context potentially could be improved so
actually for example now so that the
last the last paper I'm otha near this
one cousin German officer we actually
show that these results actually
generalized to other maps not David's
maps and hear that the tightest bound we
can get because week improved because
basically we can prove these more
general maps satisfy quantum data
balance that we have this nice
relationship between the the pets map
initial map but we can't prove the
Leeuwin to conjecture and here we we can
of Lee just use the the bound in terms
of the the measured relative entropy and
we get that's the tightest bound we can
get so yet definitely it can help yes
sorry it was a long answer
[Music]
other questions
okay there are no questions at net bank
mission again
[Applause]